(clanking in metal bowl)
- Okay, time to get some more.
Prime Day.
(electronic hip hop music)
Yeah, you heard right.
It's Prime Day.
And they got deals
on dat dat.
♫ Oh it's Prime Day
♫ They've got deals galore
♫ From cleaners for your sneakers
♫ To cleaners for your floors
♫ Headphones to shadows
♫ Laptops to Roku
♫ Pet food to water bottles
♫ And glasses to zapatos
- That's Spanish for shoes, y'all.
(slurp)
♫ Oh, it's Prime Day
♫ On 7/11
♫ Yeah, it's Prime Day
♫ Oh, it's Prime Day
♫ On 7/11
♫ And I'm runnin' out of rhymes
so brought my friend Evan
- Hi.
Hey guys, I'm Evan.
Me and here went to high school together.
♫ Order your Echo
♫ Curl up with your Kindle
♫ Buy a fly watch
♫ And just watch the time dwindle
♫ Makeup for the gurus
♫ Hair care for your new doo
♫ Yoga mat
♫ Baseball bat
♫ And candies you can chew
♫ Deals on dat
(distorted voice)
♫ Oh it's Prime Day
♫ And I'm huntin' the deals
♫ It's Prime Day
♫ And I'm buyin' stuff on Prime Day
♫ 'Cause I'm gettin' the deals
- Put the rest of--
Put it all of it in my cart;
I want all of it in my cart right now.
I need to make a deal today,
because it's Prime Day, today.
Yep, I'm gonna press the button
and I'm gonna get all the
deals, that'll be online.
♫ Go Prime Day
♫ It's your Prime Day
♫ Get busy
♫ Go hard
♫ Go
- (sigh) Prime Day's coming, yes.
(ding)